[Música]
eu sou luciano pereira alves
e como diria carlinhos brown eu tenho
duas vozes
essa aqui eles acabaram de ouvir e essa
outra que vai contar uma pequena
história pra todos vocês estavam lá como
é que se constrói uma carreira
será que é tão fácil quanto sei lá
prepara um golo a gente pega dois ovos
manteiga farinha leite mas tudo a limpo
temos uma receita pronta diante da gente
acho que não né eu acredito que só
vivendo mesmo só vivendo para entender
como é que uma carreira funciona
eu vou fazer melhor do que a do começo
eu sou luciene não se eu sou lucy e sua
mulher muito normal assim como um como a
maioria das mulheres que estão aqui
presentes eu tive uma infância muito
divertida muito livre aqui em joão
pessoa
sempre fui muito menina muito é k sempre
gostei de subir em árvore e brincar em
casa com os pés cheios de calos enfim
sempre foi muito criança
acho que ainda sou e é a minha família
como na maioria de muitas famílias
me incentivou a se meus pais sempre me
incentivaram a fazer esporte ea fazer
dança curso de línguas mas a música
sempre foi o grande trunfo da família
sempre foi muito presente né então aos
quatro anos de idade a gente brincava de
boneca eu minha irmã seu lar e
suavizante e ao mesmo tempo a gente ia
para a orquestra infantil do estado da
paraíba
lá eu vi o primeiro protagonismo como
instrumentista lá eu aprendi um violino
foi meu primeiro instrumento de porco
com 14 anos de idade eu já frequentava o
clube do choro da paraíba
aí nessa época eu já tocava viola ano já
tocava um bocado de coisa tocava
bandolim e eu gostava de ver o clube do
choro
meu pai me levava
e incentivou e as pessoas me perguntavam
postolos meus amigos neto gosto mesmo
pra lá só tem gente mais velha e tal aí
eu adoro eu sempre me senti muito à
vontade no clube do choro sempre me
pareceu ser uma extensão da minha casa
a música sempre presente e eu sempre
gostei de no clube do choro nessa época
já tocava violino bandolim piano mas aí
o meu pai toca violão 7 cordas meus tios
toca sanfona
o meu bisavô assim como o pai de luiz
gonzaga januário tocava o fole de oito
baixos ea sanfona sempre teve e
circulando nessa folha sempre teve a
linha rodeando me paquerando sempre
muito presente na nossa família mas
engraçado que a sanfona foi um dos
últimos instrumentos pelos pelo qual
assim eu tive interesse realmente
aprender de tocar e aí eu me lembro que
eu já estava tocando baixo nessa época
né na banda livres do gueto e aí meu pai
chegou em casa sim eu estava lá para
mais de 1.000 toca no baixo com a
moléstia ele pa
luciane luciane e filha a estudar
sanfona que a sanfona vai ser a tua
grande felicidade porque olhando aquilo
eu tocava baixo e continuei lá
mal sabia eu que mais tarde depois de
muito tempo depois de nem tanto tempo
assim a sanfona seria realmente o grande
passaporte para os grandes trabalhos que
estavam por vir na minha vida ali eu
identifiquei a minha paixão de alguma
forma minha paixão pela música e vocês
com a paixão de vocês e tenho certeza
que todo mundo tem uma paixão a não
várias
mas também acredito que muita gente aqui
já se apaixonou por algum instrumento já
tem vontade de tocar instrumento né
sei lá bateria guitarra sanfona já que
cria a banda já teve banda no fundo de
garagem no quintal assim como eu também
fui lá no quintal de casa
que nasceu com o brasil na verdade não
nasceu a família ele a paraíba porque
era meu pai minha mãe minhas irmãs todo
mundo toca junto o povo ia lá a família
lima da paraíba que massa é exacerbado
essa menina tocam direitinho que você
num investem nesse grupo tão bonito tem
qualidade não sei se pesquisam vocês
tocam direito cara vocês deviam levar a
sério e mais tarde realmente nasceu clã
brasil e com quem o brasil eu viajei e
vivi durante 11 12 anos na estrada gente
visitou vários rincões do país
todos juntos a gente foi parar em
portugal e foi parar até em berlim assim
vou parar até na estônia o clã brasil
fez história
fez muita história pra mim e junto do
clã eu conheci grandes mestres pessoas
que eu escutava falar assim desde a
barriga da minha mãe
grandes mestres que me incentivaram
também e que me influenciaram de forma
muito positiva e de repente olhei aí eu
estava do lado de sivuca caracas sivuca
aqueles sanfoneiro albin e meu pai falou
é minha filha ele vai participar do
nosso dever deu sério de rap de óleo
para o outro lado
dominguinhos mestre dominguinhos com
aquela simplicidade aquela genialidade
de sempre veio participou do nosso
segundo dvd
aí depois eu olho está o seu valença com
que eu toquei dois anos também convidou
para tocar na banda dele pessoas
extraordinárias eu realmente não
imaginava poder viver aquilo tão jovem e
foi muito importante pra mim beber
aquela fonte
naquele momento eu percebi que quando a
gente faz alguma coisa com muita vontade
quando a gente faz alguma coisa com
muita paixão como a gente tem aquela
gana aquela garra a gente acredita gente
tem um objetivo muito claro diante da
gente é claro muito esforço também e
obviamente uma pitadinha de sorte as
coisas acontecem acontecem sim as coisas
vão aparecer no nosso caminho as
surpresas acontecem e mais uma vez uma
surpresa maravilhosa o clã brasil é
indicado ao grammy latino e
tá olha aí rapaz quem diria hein
essa banda genuinamente paraibana as
meninas fizeram seu cd aqui em joão
pessoa
platão lá foram indicadas ao oscar da
música latino-americana foi o clã brasil
foi muito importante beber realmente
dessas fontes tudo isso trouxe esse
bocado de coisa bacana pra gente mas
sabe que nem sempre foi assim
sabia que nunca foi o meu sonho de fato
ser cantora
os e artista não era meu sonho de
criança tinha sabe que as pessoas chegam
lucy mas caraca aconteceu tão rápido e
tão sempre sonhou com isso né
desde menino sempre quis ser famosa eu
não jurei mão eo garoto queria ser eu a
sei lá eu queria ser médica e então tá
bom eu primeiro vestibular foi pra
medicina eu fiz vestibular para medicina
eu não passei medicina
depois eu botei na minha cabeça que eu
queria fazer nutrição aí está certo
fui lá eu fiz a prova passei a primeira
etapa
fiquei bem classificado que em 25º lugar
a itabom estava me preparando para a
prova específica como se fosse hoje
estava tendo um show
acho que era aquele festival mundo que
acontecerá no busto de tamandaré e aí
até um show de lenine
aí o pessoal vamos lá a luz vai ter show
cara não tem prova eu vou descansar
dormir vou me resguardar o dome cedo vou
me alimentar direitinho e assim eu fiz é
todo mundo foi eu fiquei em casa ficará
camanho por da cdu já umas coisinhas
aqui fui dormir e no outro dia eu não
acordei ninguém acordou na minha casa eu
não fiz vestibular para nutrição
não era pra ser voltar a perder esses
dois vestibulares aí eu botei na cabeça
que precisava realmente era ter uma
estabilidade financeira disse eu vou
fazer direito que direito vai
me dá uma boa base vou ter dinheiro
o támbém na vida eu fiz direito aí
passei fiz o primeiro período fiz
segundo período terceiro período quarto
aí quarto período o dólar
naquela de direito maravilhosa o coração
nada é tanto em que nada eu não sentia
nada eu não sabia se era aquilo mesmo
que eu queria mas eu realmente não
estava feliz e 1 hora eu parei fiz
caraca lucy luz
a musicista mulher que gosta de música
olha só de êxito na seu trouxa de música
é tudo vai fazer vestibular para música
fiz vestibular para música mas nessa
época eu já tocava profissionalmente
fiz o meu vestibular e aí terminei meu
curso em família sempre lá me apoiando
né família linda e um dia eu estava
prestes a cometer um pequeno deslize e
pensei em fazer um concurso público e
fazer um concurso público e aí sim terei
a minha estabilidade
ai meu pai para você tá doida luciane
tentadora a menina você nunca ser
artista você quer ser artista
se eu quero mas é difícil a ele pois
então enquanto estiver aqui você vai ser
artista eu não vou deixar faltar nada
para você
se você fizer esse concurso você vai
ficar presa aqui luciani
você não vai sair mas aqui não pensa aí
eu fiquei tá é mesmo espanhol a ele
disse
voa way we estava voando mundo e lá do
outro lado estava acontecendo as
audições para a segunda temporada do the
voice brasil e aí um belo dia eu cheguei
na minha aula de pilates como professor
daniel almeida 6 horas da manhã como
sempre lucy o galo da madrugada fui pra
lá e ele falou lucy do já ouvi falar no
the voice brasil diz carol escutei
alguma coisa mas eu nem sei direito como
o programa funciona
ele poderia se inscrever saber porque é
um show de calouros que está passando na
televisão e revela talentos
tudo pensando em ir lá pode ser
e aí eu fui pra casa com aquela ideia a
chegar em casa jogar ainda na mesa a
gente tava comendo é o meu pai minha mãe
olha tem um programa que é assim assado
chama de voz brasil de voz brasil que
vocês acham meu pai deve se inscrever
aí eu tenho certeza ele deve se
inscrever mas eu tava se inscrever
tá mas será que eu vou ter espaço será
que eu sei lá eu com a minha sanfona vou
ter um espaço lá de voz do brasil
a ele eu tenho certeza que vão escolher
eu tenho certeza que vão escolher sendo
faz o seguinte você se inscreve semana o
vídeo e aí quando eles escolherem você
escolhe se você quer ir ou não dá nada
né seu lado certo
aí eu gravei um vídeo bem caseiro e
mandei no último dia de inscrição
aí quando eu vi já estava lá tava lá
cheguei lá naquele auditório frio cheio
de gente um silêncio tão nado
eu como eu vi cidinho azul aí a cadeira
virá da receita o que eu estou fazendo
aqui é um tremendo pé a cabeça mesmo eu
acho que eu nunca me senti tão nervosa
na minha vida como naquele dia de
verdade nem antes nem depois
aquele foi um dos dias que me deixou
mais aterrorizar assim eu estava dura
sem saber o que fazer e esperando o aval
daquelas pessoas
aí sempre o privilégio de ter esta
parceira aqui eu olhei pra ela né de ser
mulher só tem nós agora disse
agora é tudo las cair aí a gente começou
a tocar aí carlinhos brown pá bateu o
italiano escopo que ele está vendo ajuda
agora
daqui a pouco lupah bateu de novo agora
class comemora rocha o noe [ __ ] velha
ea gente tocou e quando eu vi a gente já
estava na final
o the voice me abriu muitas portas sem
dúvida um dos maiores divisores de água
da minha carreira porque em três meses
eu tive uma visibilidade que eu não tive
em 12 anos de carreira
foram 12 anos de carreira e foi um tempo
muito necessário também porque foi esse
tempo conclui brasil que me deu a minha
base para chegar lá e fazer o que sabe
fazer de melhor
mas também para saber escolher os
caminhos que estavam por vir depois
aquele convite
depois daquela oportunidade e um de vós
se sim me abriu muitas portas depois do
de voz vieram vários convites é um
convite pra teste de minissérie dois
irmãos ver um convite para um musical
nuvem de lágrimas e ver um convite para
o velho chico a novela que catapultou
para o brasil como atriz então foram
novos desafios que apareceram diante de
mim eu sempre gostei do desafio eu
peguei tudo peguei eu me jogo eu sabia
também que ao mesmo tempo que eu tava
ganhando eu estava perdendo algumas
coisas e também estava aparecendo novos
desafios já tem ali um protagonismo com
o brasil com a música no de voz agora um
protagonismo no velho chico e com isso
vieram muitas críticas eram muitas
críticas
os estereótipos e olá sanfoneiro e agora
pode ser atriz mas menina deixa ela
então a só sair porque é bonita ela não
ela deve conhecer algum político por
isso que eu entrando depois saber ou
então se sabia que ela só tem essa
visibilidade na novela porque ela está
namorando o diretor esse tipo de coisa
eu escutei um bocado mas esse tipo de
coisa não me abalou não pelo contrário
eu peguei tudo aquilo me fortaleceu
eu peguei tudo eu escutei tudo eu li e
aí eu parei e fui buscá lá dentro de mim
lá dentro de mim mesmo porque o melhor
da gente está sempre dentro da gente eo
meu melhor a música foi com a música que
eu construí luzia eu decorava os meus
isso com a música todo e acordava fazer
o meu cafezinho e botava um pouco lá
encaixam nas falas naquela métrica
naquele ritmo ea música e luzia levaram
à premiação ganhei prêmio de atriz
revelação e como eu falei ganhando
tantas coisas e também perdendo alguns
porque eu estava usando novos vôos e eu
estava ali deixando um pouco a minha
família os meus amigos aquele aconchego
aquela fortaleza
sim eu tenho um laço muito estreito
saque
o estado com a cidade sempre foi muito
pegada muito e saí me dói
ainda tenho saudades mas se eu que saí
porque estava querendo alguma coisa mais
eu estava querendo sair de dentro da
caixinha eu queria mais e foi isso que
me fez voar um pouco mais longe e
perceber que eu naquele momento era
realmente a protagonista da minha
história da minha vida do meu trabalho
eu fui com ela essa fona a minha arte
que eu sempre acreditei que a minha arte
buscava provocar as pessoas é colocar
algum sentimento ea minha arte sempre
trouxe também uma forma muito verdadeiro
meu povo é o povo nordestino caboclo
isso todas as minhas heranças indígenas
negras a minha força de mulher
essa força que realmente me fez e um
pouco mais longe assumir as rédeas da
minha vida e claro eu sei que meu sonho
mas todo mundo tem um sonho
todo mundo tem um dom todo mundo tem uma
vontade tem uma arte também ea gente tem
que pegar
tem que se apropriar disso tem que dar o
primeiro passo tem que acreditar muito
tem que pensar positivo sempre eu faço
sempre isso aprendi com a minha mãe é o
mais importante de tudo que eu acho que
a gente tem que se permite voar
obrigada
[Aplausos]